A hash function can be applied
to a block of data of any size.
A hash function produces
an output of fixed size.
Typically in the range
of 128 bits to 512 bits.
It should be very efficient
to compute a hash of a input.
For given hash value it should
be computationally infeasible
to find the input so that the hash
matches the given hash value.
That is a hash function
should be a one way function.
Given the input data say m1,
it should be computationally infeasible
to find another input value,
say m2 that is not equal to m1.
Such that they have the same hash value.
This is the weak collision
resistant property.
The strong collision resistant
property is such that it should be
computationally infeasible
to five different inputs,
m1 not equal to m2 such that
they have the same hash value.
The first three properties make
hash functions practical for
security applications.
In particular,
it can handle data of any size, and
it's very efficient to compute hash.
The one way property says that it's
quite easy to compute a hash value
given a message, but
it is virtually impossible to find or
generate input message.
Given a hash value.
This property is very important for
message authentication.
For example,
we can authenticate a message by hashing
a secret value together
with the message.
The secret is not sent,
the hash and the message is sent.
If the hash function is not one-way,
then the attacker
being able to intercept the hash
value that's being transmitted.
He can then find an input
that computes the hash value.
And the input would
include the secret value,
that is the attacker would be
able to obtain the secret value.
Therefore, this one way property
is extremely important.
The weak collision resistant
property says that for
given message, it is not possible
to find a different message,
such that it will have the same
hash value as the given message.
This is a very important property
to ensure message integrity.
Now let's take a closer look at this
weak collision resistant property.
Suppose when a sender sends
a message to the receiver,
he wants to ensure
the integrity of the message.
So the sender sends a message along with
an encrypted hash code of the message.
Now an attacker can
intercept the message, and
the encrypted hash code
that is being transmitted.
Given a message, the attacker
can also compute the hash code.
Of course this hash
code is not encrypted,
because the attacker
does not have the key.
Then if the weak collision
resistant poverty is not true.
The attacker will be able
to find another message,
such that each hash value is the same as
the hash value of the original message.
Then the hacker simply forwards to
the receiver the forged message,
along with the original
encrypted hash code.
The receiver will not be able
to tell that the message
has been modified by the attacker.
Because the forged message has
exactly the same hash value
as the original message.
The strong collision resistant property,
says that it is not possible to find
any pair of two different messages, so
that they have the same hash value.
It should be obvious that the strong
collision resistant property
implies the weak collision
resistant property.
The weak collision resistant property
means that the hash function
is collision resistant.
Only to the specific
given input messages.
Whereas the strong collision resistant
property, means that the hash function
is collision resistant to any
pair of different messages.
Therefore, this is stronger property and
it implies the weaker property.
The strong collision resistant property,
provides strong message authenticity and
integrity protection.
Let's take a look at an example.
Suppose Bob did some work for Alice,
and he wants Alice to pay him later.
So he can draft a IOU message and
ask Alice to sign and
then agree to pay for it.
To sign the message,
Alice will hash the IOU message.
And then sign the hash
using her private key.
This will prove that Alice
authorized the IOU message.
In other words, Alice would
agree to pay this amount later.
In a later day, Bob can present this
IOU message, along with the signature,
to Alice or
Alice's bank to get the money.
Now suppose the strong collision
resistant property is not true.
That would mean that Bob can
find two different messages,
one with a smaller dollar amount.
For example,
this small amount can be just one
installment of Alice's payment to Bob.
And the larger amount would be
several times the amount of money
that Alice owes Bob.
And if these two messages have the same
hash value, then Bob can present
the message with a small amount
to Alice, and have Alice sign it.
Bob can present a signature
with a different message.
That is, the message with a larger
amount, and ask Alice to pay for it.
And because these two different
messages have the same hash value,
Alice can not deny
that she has signed it.
That means that Alice can not deny that
she has agreed to pay
this larger amount.